salut c'est soprano pour brut dans ma
vie qui m'a marqué c'est le moment où
j'ai rencontré à cannes at home c'est un
truc de fou parce que nous on était
petit avec mon groupe les psy4 de la
rime
on écoutait iam comme tout le monde
notre didier si les styles paix à son
âme nous appelle nous dit akhenaton qui
va nous appeler en lice est une blague
il a raccroché il croyait pas le disais
c'est le lag akhenaton zapper le
téléphone sonne
oui c'est pas une blague sakana tonnes
j'aimerais bien vous rencontrer et vous
proposer quelque chose si vous voulez on
se donne rendez vous dans un resto à
marseille tel endroit un restaurant
italien et où il raccroche quoi qu'elle
attend tous est un truc de fou première
chose qu'on saisit nous n'a jamais tout
restaurant de nuit
on va pas au rendez vous d'habitude on
parle beaucoup de la preuve on parle
beaucoup on rigole beaucoup ont fait la
fête et tout mais là la can at home
devant il est il est avec sa femme je me
rappellerai toute ma vie il avait des
lunettes quartier il avait une veste en
cuir bombers ce bombardier bombardier
avec de la laine j'imagine ce que je te
dis ça fait ça fait 20 ans qu'il sera
mais je me répète on arrive dans le
resto il arrive libre jours tel convoi
de m normal alors que nous on imagine
écouter ses chansons restait mafieux
c'était un intello de chez sait pas où
on imaginait trop des trucs de faux
akhenaton devant nous on regarde un peu
à droite à gauche mais pourquoi il ya
deux fourchettes de couteau
deux assiettes est quoi ce bordel on
regarde à quels atomes qu'est ce qu'il
fait il faut imaginer quatre mecs de
quartier on était presque avec tee shirt
déchiré survêtement à la casquette comme
maintenant là comme ça dans un resto
chic on n'était pas prêts on n'était pas
prêt et en plus avec hématome devant
nous mais j'aimerais bien aussi une
édition il ne parle un peu de la musique
du diois j'aimerais bien aussi m'occuper
de vous c'est un truc de fou
et depuis ce jour jusqu'à maintenant
c'est le mec qui nous donne toujours des
conseils de la sortie no 2 albums solo
en nos deux albums en groupe psy4 de la
rime en indépendant parce que les gens
ils ne savent pas mais c'était
indépendance a sorti de sa poche et
d'associer nos albums
les deux ont fait disque d'or en
indépendant qui la donne a changé ma vie
dans plein de trucs à travers ses textes
bien sûr mais je pensais pas comment
mais à travers son ce qui m'a tout ce
qui m'a conseillé tout ce qu'il a fait
pour pour chaque membre des psy4 de la
rime
un des moments qui m'a marqué dans ma
vie aussi la sortie de mon premier album
solo il était très attendu j'aime
beaucoup de pression mais le problème
c'est que j'étais au moment où
j'écrivais cet album mais au moment où
il y avait le buzz
j'avais des gros problèmes perso khimki
qui me faisait oublier la pression de 2
comment s'appelle du buzz de la musique
de la maison de disques des fans de tous
ces trucs là que j'avais des problèmes
personnels qui m'ont poussé au point
d'aller d'arriver au point de vouloir
enlever la vie c'était c'était trop loin
tout ça et du coup comment s'appelle il
fallait que je me remette dans l'album
et je me suis dit si je fais l'album
il faut que je le fasse par rapport à
comme je suis maintenant faut que
j'arrête de mes conneries de mélancolie
où je veux me voulait m'enlever la vie
où j'étais noir et tout ça je les décris
dans cet album là et je me suis dit
l'album vais l'appeler puisqu'il faut
vivre parce que dans tous les cas on
aura des problèmes
autant le faire avec le sourire et et à
travers cet album je me suis dit je veux
mettre en mots thérapie d'oublier
l'album j'oubliais les femmes
j'oublie la maison disque et je les fais
comme si tu es une thérapie j'ai tout
mis dans cet album pour me soigner à la
base cet album il a changé ma vie parce
que depuis maintenant je suis concentré
que sur le message que sur le fond et
que sur quelque chose qui ce qui est
utile aux gens le stade vélodrome
le premier concert au stade vélodrome
c'était un truc de malade parce que
jamais dans ma vie j'aurais cru que
j'aurais fait le stade vélodrome
l'endroit où je vais avoir mon équipe
préférée jouer et jamais j'aurais cru
que les gens seraient venus pour me voir
bon c'est un truc de malade alors la
journée je me suis levé le matin déjà
j'y croyais pas me suis dit ah merde le
temps il est passé vite parce que la
date on avait mis un an et demi avant
donc du coup quand je me suis levé je me
suis dit [ __ ] c'est un truc de fou
le temps comme il n'a pas cessé ce soir
je n'arrivais pas à y croire
partout je marchais c'était à ce soir
j'avais l'impression qu'ils avaient mais
j'ai même pas l'impression il y avait
toute la ville qui était qui était venue
du coup c'était pas un concert comme si
c'était la pression elle était
différente et pas une pression mais j'ai
peur comment ça se passe et c'était je
sentais que les gens étaient tellement
contents que même pour eux c'était
important
ça veut dire que même pour eux c'était
une pression parce que ils me
regardaient plus comme
ça arrive il me regardait comme l'enfant
du pays on va on va être avec lui quand
je suis arrivé au stade j'ai regardé la
scène on avait répété la veille quand
même je me suis mis dans un coin du
stade
je regardais la scène j'étais tout seul
père qu'on fait ça c'est la première
fois que les personnes n'avaient ça
j'étais en haut je me suis dit comme ça
j'ai regardé city non et là j'ai vu ma
vie défiler
je me suis vu quand j'étais au plan de
bas avec moi d'amour avec mon groupe je
me suis vu quand qu'on a commencé à
faire mes premiers concerts dans les mjc
je me suis vu comment s'est essayée avec
mon groupe a essayé de s'incruster dans
les scènes où il y avait d'autres
artistes mais suivi sortir le premier
album la rencontre avec akhenaton le
premier album solo comment s'appellent
les tournées les succès les albums qui
se monte petit à petit est arrivé au
stade de bram et là je me suis dit waouh
j'ai pris un coup dessus mais ici c'est
incroyable j'ai est en fait je me suis
senti fier en fait je suis senti fier de
ce qu'ils voient là on n'a pas travaillé
pour rien